let's now speak to some of those very
folks in our audience we do this on the
Friday show we do it via Discord you can
find the Discord at davidpackman.com
slash uh Discord that is the place to do
it we are going to start today with John
from Connecticut John from Connecticut
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
hey can you hear me yes
cool so
um my question is more along the lines
of
why does it seem like so many people
nowadays especially on the right seem to
have a problem with any critical
thinking like it's so hard for people to
understand to like you know look at a
situation that they're not used to
understanding and they can't like they
just immediately jump to conclusions two
answers to that number one there are
some people
who just have not been taught how to
think critically and so they don't right
and in a sense you can't blame them to a
degree because if you haven't been
taught something how can you be expected
to know how to do it on the other hand
there are those on the right who
recognize that when people really apply
basic critical thinking and media
literacy techniques to right-wing
ideology it very quickly falls apart and
this is why those who are wise to this
actually don't want critical thinking
taught in schools they realize if too
many people start thinking critically
it's bad for the Republican party so
it's a combination of ignorance and bad
faith actors and in some cases maybe a
combination of the two
what do you think is more prevalent bad
faith actors or people who are just
ignorant I think among vote the average
voter I think it's ignorance and listen
the left is not exempt from this by any
means there is a lack of critical
thinking on left and right and we could
slice and dice it but I think that the
vast majority of those who aren't
thinking critically aren't thinking
critically because of ignorance not
because they are bad faith actors
they've been sort of indoctrinated
as a result of not thinking for
themselves in a critical way and it's
really an indictment on the educational
system and the media system as well
right
um so the last thing then is what do you
think would be the best way to like talk
to the people who are more ignorant that
are kind of easier to you know maybe
give them some evidence to hopefully
change their mind on that type of
situation the best path for the folks
you're talking about is actually not to
give them evidence it's to know how to
use a gentle empathetic Socratic method
of questioning to get them to say hey
maybe I'm not actually that solid in
what I believe so it's where did you
learn that oh how do you know that's
trustworthy in general how do you know
what things are trustworthy what's a
good way of figuring out what to believe
that approach rather than beating people
over the head with evidence is probably
going to be more effective
all right thank you very much David all
right John from Connecticut great to
hear from you why don't we go next to
Nicole from Utah Nicole Welcome to the
program
thank you so much David uh my question
this time is actually going to be
related to what Trump has said in
relation to the Ukraine war do you think
he has any chance if he does get elected
which is a long shot anyways does he
have any amount of chance at stopping
this war
like he claims listen he will he says
let's go through it in Parts Trump says
he will end the Russian invasion of
Ukraine in 24 hours
when he's asked how he says oh I'll talk
to them pretty silly pretty dumb the
only way that I see that conflict is
ending quickly
would be if basically Ukraine gives up
and Russia just takes over so even in
the best scenario it's not going to end
in 24 hours now does Trump have a chance
at actually ending it I think he does
have a chance in the sense that every
every president has a chance the the
question is the the detail of how you
would actually do it but sure I mean
Trump has a chance he just doesn't have
a great track record that makes me think
it's it's highly likely
mm-hmm
that's all I have for you today David
all right thank you Nicole Nicole from
Utah great to hear from you uh once
again here is the perfect Father's Day
gift get him a Wi-Fi connected digital
picture frame from Aura our sponsor Aura
has been named the number one best
digital picture frame by wire cutter the
strategist and wired this is not one of
these early 2000s picture frames there's
no USB or SD cards and you get free
unlimited storage and you can instantly
frame photos and videos from any device
anywhere in the world I have several of
these I got my dad one and so now I take
pictures of the baby load them into his
Aura frame and they show up and
everybody loves it you know it's no more
of these having to bring a slideshow
When I visit I just put the pictures
right in the frame I'm really glad I got
him one of these and right now Aura has
a great deal for Father's Day go to
auraframes.com Pacman use the code
Pacman to get thirty dollars off plus
free shipping this deal ends June 18th
so don't wait terms and conditions apply
the link is down below